[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with kate andrews economics
correspondent at the spectator and the
political commentator benedict spence
that they both aren't ready and waiting
to go so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the prime minister has another crunch
week ahead of him according to the eye
with announcements planned on tax brexit
and the nhs to divert attention from
partygate
boris johnson is facing a backlash from
tory backbenchers over his insistence
that a 12 billion pound hike in national
insurance will go ahead that's on the
front of the metro
the daily mail has an exclusive article
to mark the second anniversary of
leaving the eu from boris johnson as he
pledges to slash red tape and boost
trade
johnson tries to take back control amid
party outrage is the headline in the
guardian
and the express also leads on the prime
minister's promise to unleash benefits
of brexit
the focus for the daily telegraph is the
health secretary sergey javid who's
expected to announce he will scrap
mandatory covered vaccines for nhs staff
the world's largest sovereign wealth
fund norway's 1.3 trillion dollar
investment pot from oil receipts has
warned of years of low returns due to
inflation
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on your screen
right now you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by kate
andrews and benedict spence welcome to
you both uh good to see you let's start
with the metro and that story that we
pointed out their headline pm facing
attacks mutiny and what what's going on
kate
so in today's the times the prime
minister and the chancellor doubled down
in a joint comment piece uh to confirm
that they are pushing ahead with the new
health and
uh health uh levy uh for the national
insurance rise which is going to equal
1.25 percentage points increase for
employers and employees um tory mps were
already very frustrated about this tax
rise coming in and they're even more so
now according to the front page of the
metro as they think with the cost of
living crisis inflation going up
now is not the time for tax rises i
think there's a very important point to
be made here about the cost of living at
the moment but it is also frustrating in
the sense that i think only 10 tory mps
voted against this tax hike in the
commons last year there was of course an
opportunity to push back on it and the
hard truth is that now that the policy
has been promised that we're essentially
going to protect the assets of those who
are wealthier that they won't have to
sell them off to pay for their social
care that is a very expensive policy to
the tune of billions and billions of
pounds that has to be funded uh and i
think the point that the prime minister
and the chancellor are making in the
times today which is frustrating people
but i think a tough truth that has to be
realized that if you are going to have
that policy the money has to come from
somewhere now the prime minister has
ruled out making cuts elsewhere that
means taxes are going up these are the
uh tough trade-offs of wanting to spend
more cash
we're going to try and sort out your
signed little bit of interference uh
with you there okay but uh let's move on
to to benedict i mean nps is saying that
well rebel conservative mps according to
this article want it it's scrapped but
that ain't going to happen is it
no it's not and you can sort of
you can imagine the frustrations of a
lot of conservative voters who believe
that they were getting uh a low tax sort
of thatcherite prime minister and as
often has been uh feared about boris
johnson he's not he's nothing of the
sort uh he is somebody who makes very
bold promises about infrastructure about
leveling up about sorting out the nhs
those things are all inevitably going to
lead to tax reforms i mean that's just
the nature of the sort of prime minister
that we have and then when of course
when you add the pandemic and all the
measures that were sort of taken to
safeguard the nhs as a result of that
again you were only ever sort of heading
in one direction i mean what's what's
also slightly frustrating is uh this eye
piece for example a metropolis sorry it
it it uh asks other mps tory mps uh how
they feel a lot of them say that they
are very unhappy and robert hoffman for
example gives an indication of where
else we can get money from he says well
we we could go after capital gains tax
and it is that sort of feeling of so
either way it is a tax that is you know
taxes are going to go up
and i do feel that yeah as much as kate
says you know that these these are
things that have been promised and you
know there are plugs to be filled
um
with this massive sort of increase in
the cost of living that's coming with
you know inflation and energy prices
soaring it just couldn't really come at
a worse time with businesses sort of
just sort of getting back on their feet
everything sort of trying to get back to
normal to then start slapping people
with taxes whatever the promises were
made at the time of the last general
election and whatever the problems with
the public person it is going to cause
an awful lot of pain for ordinary men
and women on the street and it's another
thing i think really that the
conservative party need to worry about
amid the furore around boris johnson's
personality it's not simply going to be
a question come the next election of who
held what party when it is how much
money people have left in their pocket
and that is something that will probably
end up spooking a lot of back bench mps
the longer this goes on for
it certainly was reported previously
that this was something that the prime
minister was thinking seriously about
perhaps doing a u-turn on but now we see
this this joint uh article with the
chancellor ishisunak um do you think
that the prime minister has had to be
brought dragging and screaming round to
to rishi sunek's point of view
i mean it's interesting isn't it because
we've been hearing haven't we all for
the last couple of weeks that you know
mps who were previously very hostile to
the prime minister they've suddenly been
getting meetings with the pm that
they've been trying to get but for
months now and we've been hearing
haven't we either talk about well could
rishi sunak launch a leadership bid
could he be a viable alternative it
would certainly be i would have
certainly thought that in the short term
uh it's not necessarily in russia's
united's best interest to launch a
leadership bid but of course he is a
threat to boris johnson so it might you
you might well have a case there by
saying that you know the prime minister
perhaps in order to fend off the
slightly more militant wing of his of
his party who aren't particularly
enamored with him at the moment is
having to be brought ever so slightly to
heal to keep the more
the the more vocal factions on side for
the time being i mean the prime minister
certainly seems confident in his
position for now but that will involve
an awful lot of wheeling and dealing and
having to make merry with people that he
needs to be friends with that
unfortunately for him includes his own
chancellor hmm politics for you um let's
move on to the
the the telegraph um their headline
their middle class is facing lifetime
one million tax bill i mean that will
terrify anyone reading that headline
wouldn't it
well again yes this is going to cause
yeah it touches on what i was just
saying which is that a lot of people
were already feeling the pinch and we've
been hearing these sort of you know the
talk about you know the impending fuel
increases and everything that's coming
down the line and this is the sort of
the classic issue i think for the
tourists having you know sort of tried
to forge itself into the party of the
working class by taking the red wall
seats from the labor party and you know
trying to reforge itself in the image of
the art and brexit here a lot of you
know remember the folks back home so to
say a lot of you know classic tory
voters they remain the middle classes
and as i say they are the ones that were
hoping for you know a low tax prime
minister they were hoping for things to
slightly go back to the way they were
less red tape less government
intervention and they're getting the
opposite you know prices are going up
everything is getting very difficult and
on top of that taxes are going to be
laid on them and i think the real fear
that a lot of voters will have is
yes we're talking now about short-term
taxes you know one or two taxes hey
who's to say other things won't go up i
mentioned you know capital gains tax
just then who's to say that that might
not go up in addition to increases on
national uh insurance contributions in
the future that has got to be the thing
that will be weighing
very heavily over an awful lot of voters
and will continue to do so for the next
two years
and again it's it's not simply a
question i think for the prime minister
of retaking control and moving on from
partygate and oh isn't this all a load
of nonsense long term
faith in the prime minister which did
abound in quite large amounts yeah there
was a lot of good will towards him for a
very long time it has finally evaporated
and i think he's going to discover that
for all he was very popular before he's
going to find it very difficult i think
to win a lot of that good faith back yes
and uh uh rishi shunak and the prime
minister insist that uh they are they're
tax cutting conservatives and and
thatcherites as if to say you know these
aren't our core values we still believe
in in tax cuts kate
yeah this is the difficulty is that
saying that phrase over and over again
isn't what makes it true you actually do
have to cut taxes meaningfully along the
way and i do think that is the ultimate
goal by the way
uh for both both forest johnson and
rishi sunak um rishi cena does not like
raising taxes but he dislikes not fully
costing policies even more as the
taxpayers alliance uh highlights today
though and on the front page of the
telegraph it now means that if you are a
middle class earner you're spending
roughly 18 years of work uh paying off
the tax man and that is very difficult
reality for a so-called low tax prime
minister to be
overseeing um it's a reminder of of just
how badly the situation has actually
gone under this conservative prime
minister taxes are at a 71-year high and
there's been a lot of criticism today
with that times article uh with this
insistence that they are low to tax
conservatives they might want to be but
you actually have to cut some taxes in
order to call yourself that
benedict the eye suggesting that the the
pm's fight back uh distraction away from
partygate and and everything else is
isn't working
well kel surprise i think you know
having you know having sort of ridden
the way for as long as he did and as i
said there was a lot of you know a lot
of people were prepared to give the
prime minister a lot of chances a lot of
time because the situation that he found
himself in was very unusual but i do
think that having squandered that and
done that himself i just don't think
it's going to be something that people
forget you know you hear every day don't
you the the stories of people who had to
bury loved ones in the same week that
these parties were going on whose you
know children were you know being shot
out of education who weren't able to
attend you know all sorts of important
events themselves and these things are
gonna stick in the mind they're not
going to go away
and
it doesn't matter sort of how much you
know boris johnson now sort of tries to
bring back the the terminology of brexit
you know leveling up and you know taking
back control he i'm afraid has lost
control of the narrative
and he's lost control of great swathes
of his party as much as he's able to
hang on for the time being he is there
but i believe that simply because there
isn't a viable alternative that's
currently made themselves um available
to the rest of the party he is
effectively a dead man walking and he
might talk a good game
about you know about being able to uh
bring it all back ultimately i just
can't see him i can't see the pull i
can't see the party itself keeping him
in place ahead of the next general
election because they must know people
are not going to forgive boris johnson
and his government for breaking their
trust in this way and the key thing for
the conservative party will be to try to
rid themselves of that toxicity before
it affects the rest of the party
meanwhile kate the foreign secretary
accepts that the sugree report is a bit
of a mess quote um but insists that
johnson will lead tories into the next
election
well it would be difficult to keep a
spot in cabinet right now if if you
weren't um on this group is backing the
prime minister anyway um so i think that
the the real uh change from the past few
weeks is that just the deep incompetency
of the met police coming in so late in
the game and then asking sue gray uh to
retract or just to keep um certain uh
bits of the parties that were uh going
on to a minimum in her report has bought
the prime minister some time now look
anything could happen none of us make
predictions anymore um but it does seem
that he has a bit of time and that's
what you're seeing on the front of the
eye i think the guardian and the male
today these plans that the prime
minister has with this time that he's
frankly been gifted even if accidentally
so to try to remind the public
especially those red wall voters those
who lent their vote to the conservative
party who may not be fully signed up
members to the party from the 2019
election uh that he does have their best
interest at heart the question is
whether or not it will work and i think
you know flagging this brexit freedom's
bill flagging leveling up flagging all
the things that they have had some time
to do even with cobra that they haven't
done yet it could go both ways perhaps
voters will be convinced that you know
the prime minister's back to business
going to deliver for them they might
also remember all the things he hasn't
achieved yet and frankly put to the side
uh when him and his aides were having a
few drinks and some wine and cheese in
the back garden of downing street uh so
i agree with benedict it's still a very
difficult sell to the public but with
this bit more time he's going to try to
focus on public policy and remind people
why they ushered in men in 2019 with a
huge majority in the first place we
shall see if that is effective uh
caitlyn benedict for the minute thank
you we are going to take a break coming
up
is it the end for vaccine mandate for
nhs staff we'll be discussing that next
animal
[Music]
watching the press preview still with me
kate andrews economics correspondent at
the spectator and the political
commentator benedict spence welcome back
to both of you let's have a look at the
telegraph and the telegraph reporting
here that you turn on mandatory jobs for
nhs workers um has to say that that
hasn't that hasn't been um agreed and
that that hasn't been negotiated it's a
bit of a speculative headline isn't it
uh kate
yeah so it looks like health secretary
sachi javid is going to be bringing this
option to the covet o group this week
and the telegraph seems to understand he
will be looking to u-turn but as you
point out
certainly not confirmed yet uh it's
thought that this week roughly around
the first week of february would be the
last opportunity for non-jabbed nhs
workers to get their first job in order
to line up with the provisions that you
have to be double jabs by april in order
to keep your job it is now estimated
that this could result between 80 and a
hundred thousand nhs staff losing their
jobs um that was never going to be a
real possibility for the nhs the system
and forget a coverage year in a normal
year the system is strained especially
throughout the winter um really at
almost any time you know it's designed
to operate in your capacity the idea
that you might lose so many workers just
wasn't going to be sustainable
especially for all the patients covered
and non-coveted who are already having
to wait hours naini queueing
in ambulances outside of hospitals
struggling to get gp appointments and
the rest of it um so the u-turn in that
sense isn't terribly surprising but one
of the reasons people did think it was
going to go ahead is because a similar
gauntlet was laid down with care home
workers and many have lost their jobs
it's so hard to get official figures on
that but we know that many care home
workers have been fired for not getting
jabbed so it did seem plausible that the
health secretary might push forward with
this but it's clear that weighing up
those risks it is simply not worth it to
lose those unjabbed health care workers
at the moment and it looks like he'll be
looking it looks like he'll be working
to u-turn now yeah benedict that looks
so almost certain i mean i say it's
speculative that the headline but with
talking about 80 000 workers losing that
from the nhs at this time during a
pandemic it's it's not feasible as kate
says
it's not and i mean as kate says it
would have the potential to a a
an institution which is already sort of
running on fumes at the best of times
and the thing is you know we're talking
again about the prime minister the
government trying to regain some form of
popularity having managed to fritter all
of it away well how popular do you think
they're going to be after two years of
being told you have to put your life on
hold to protect the nhs
then to see your government gut the nhs
and potentially see backlogs in all
kinds of things be it you know
cancer or any or whatever it is i don't
think people would take too kindly to
that you also i think begin to raise
questions and you know shine a spotlight
on why it is that so many nhs workers uh
haven't got the job and you you run the
risk i think if you keep on going back
to this and saying you know 80 000 100
000 big numbers many people haven't had
the jab more ordinary members of the
public who might otherwise have had the
jab might start to think themselves well
hang on if the medics aren't having it
done if the people in the nhs aren't
having done maybe i don't want to have
it done and i do think you possibly
through trying to sort of force people
to have it you might end up having
the opposite effect of not only
crippling the health service but also
perhaps making more people in the public
at last begin to question whether or not
they need it
yeah it might be that the the actual um
requirement is suspended that might be
the the the u-turn so we don't know
exactly how far they're going to go
let's um just got time to go to the
metro um and kate take us into uh this
sort of semi-row although uh harry and
megan are deciding to stay with spotify
but um bring us up to date on what
they're saying their criticism of
spotify
yes the topics of big tech in cancel
culture have have met over the past few
days as neil young decided to pull his
music from spotify uh unless they
tackled or essentially took down the joe
rogan podcast which i think is the most
listened to and successful podcast in
the world because rogan has been
interviewing people who take a vaccine
skeptic position now it looks like harry
and megan don't want to give up their 25
million deal with spotify and pulled
their podcast yet but they have
suggested that they're uncomfortable
with the podcast being hosted um you
know this takes us into much much bigger
conversations about the power of big
tech um what it means to try to cancel
people um you know whether or not we
want this information to be publicly
available even if we disagree with it it
looks like harry and megan um aren't
going to be pulling their podcast just
yet but it'll be interesting to see how
spotify responds to the pressure being
mounted whether or not for them this is
a pure and straightforward business
decision or whether or not they're going
to commit to the principles of free
speech on their platform and that they
want to host all kinds of podcast and
music uh even if they disagree with it
of course you know censoring music in
particular has been a huge topic
throughout the decades uh one that i
thought we were finally coming down on
the right side of but um it seems like
some artists uh do you still have very
strong opinions about what should and
shouldn't be listened to uh very quickly
benedict if they're not going to leave
spotify does it matter that they've
stood up and and made these comments
no it doesn't um as with all of these
things when it comes to council culture
it's all about money we've seen this
with people being cancelled for example
uh on the side of the trans debate uh
when it gets to somebody like jk rowling
who is worth billions uh suddenly you
find yourself unable to cancel that
person because they're worth too much
money and it's the same with joe rogan
podcast i think spotify bought the right
state's po podcast for 100 million
dollars they ain't going to get rid of
that anytime soon i mean certainly not
for joni mitchell and neil young no
offense and again you've seen it it
doesn't matter how uncomfortable meghan
and harry are they ain't going to
believe in the platform if they aren't
going to be getting their money either
that's ultimately what a lot of this
comes down to cancel culture is
ultimately in many ways about
consumerism and when there's too much
money at stake people aren't prepared to
cancel
benedict and kate not canceling you but
just putting you on pause
till the 11 30. thanks so much